[Musique]
jacques hétu la commande
on a dit un double cheese saignant une
grande bouteille d'eau une frite et un
milkshake vanille voilà sera sur place
soit en bon ok excusez moi un petit
instant de vie émis que tu es sur paris
c'est maman qui m'a dit je travaille
d'accord ça va tu installes et je te
rejoins bat pauline je prends une pause
pub bien monsieur assez lu ton c'est mon
frère
le faire mais tu vas tu rentres tu fais
ton truc tu ressors hockey rapide et
simple après tu m'appelles est la patrie
ouais
jusqu'au vrai
bon
celui ci
jamais rendez vous sur paris mais
montrant maman m'a dit que je pouvais
dormir chez toi oui mais bien sûr bien
sûr j'ai un truc de prévu ce soir ça
c'est important ça dérange pas de rester
tout seul la chanson appart
la fille du temps c'est quoi c'est en
fait c'est une fille qui d'autres pôles
dé lorik à travers les époques avec une
machine à voyager dans le temps via un
éditeur cas bien même on promet lyon
c'est pour ça que j'étais sûr par les
attentes à sortir un livre monsieur je
rentrais il ya pas mal de téléchargement
est il uniquement une histoire me
manquait d'un truc
bon ici connaissait pas grand chose sur
le passé quoi tu fais quoi là bas ça tu
vois ça c'est un unique est fixé très
vite un corps de papy et baladins du
coup elle part à la recherche de sombres
accord avec sa valise
la qui ramène aux balises et sa petite
fille je sais pas long qu'on parle des
gens comme ça ça se passe à qui je
pourrais demander où sont les toilettes
par à moi parce que je travaille ici je
manager c'est la porte au fond
[Musique]
salut sonia saisonnière ça ouais ouais
bien sûr écouté près attaquer camille
arrête tes conneries c'est une petit
frère ouais oui oui j'ai un petit frère
enfin oui est en galère du coup je
l'aide un peu vain tu as enfin je
connaissais la rue non mais il fera bon
se chiffrer en millions déjà les grands
et puis ça se trouve en fait y'a encore
les films ces milices mais les faits
sont visibles alors oui je cours je veux
sortir ce soir
ce sommet soit certes une taille de
raconter
et si tu par exxon hier tu verras compte
des trucs genre on s'entend bien jouer
ensemble quand il était petit il semble
quand même super dur contre bonjour
c'est à dire je joue avec mon frère
quand on était petit
ace combat d'avants conseiller d'état
jean fait tomber une soirée
quant aux banques si bien ici sonia
c'est pour toi c'est parti on doit les
futures là on a vu futur sonia et à
promouvoir son futur mari salut ma miss
étaient présentes dimitri et ses frères
voilà on y va des mamies en fait mener
par contre nos forces on met pas du tout
dopage auront à verser des bébés
les blacks en fait j'écris une histoire
de voyage dans le temps d'un voyage
valide ambages une agence web
oui la bienvenue a dit mme tu veux ma
playlist après jour et voilà
[Musique]
toute affaire tu parles tu danses sait
pas faire tu connais les gens d'accord
la voix
[Musique]
à
et
chien
au pouvoir lors du coup je t'ai envoyé
le lien des tropes non mais attends
regarde je mets cette veste
j'ai extrêmement chaud mais on n'est pas
à séparer les gens mais justement c'est
sa transe et c'est une entreprise qui
fait exprès de de créer les mêmes habits
pour briser les amitiés mais non
et donc cette fille elle doit trouver
des reliques à travers les époques avec
sa machine à voyager dans le temps mais
bon ils m'ont dit comme une soeur manqué
d'un truc c'est un peu vague comme
autant vous dit si je vous envie avec
mes histoires
non pas du tout c'est juste que c'est un
peu tard je vais fermer mais c'est aussi
ça t'embête pas mon petit gars moi pas
du tout
[Musique]
vous savez où sont les toilettes
chaud
le
[Musique]
non
j'ai commandé des journées à parler aux
autres voulaient en faire sa valise
saïb et retouche est examinée je voulais
te demander si tu joues tu voulais bien
mais comment résister grâce à quelques
pas pour moi je vais voir avec mon corps
you
oui
je la cuisine fait autant
j'aimerais rentrer un raté chez moi je
préfère être à la maison mon message
était commencée c'est tu peux rester ici
un écosystème mais non mais reste
profite pareil des gens j'ai parlé un
peu avec henriette non mais tu tu fais
comme les autres tu danses tu profites
voilà ça m'amuse pas être comme tout le
monde un petit peu comme un chargeur
d'un chargeur two way to va charger pour
ninon mais je compte tu t'es trompé de
soi et surtout aussi bas de gamme et je
suis moi même j'ai cherché mon téléphone
la laissez moi tranquille
non non non tu perds personne ne bouge
personne ne bouge et 15 bus et poids et
à la musique et à la musique et à la
musique
toi tu as déjà avec les autres tu vas
avec les ondes personne ne bouge
tu bouges pas tu fais quoi là tu fais
quoi tu fais quoi
viens là allez allez rebab aller là-bas
aller là bas je peux personnes aux
fenêtres et personne n'a pas les flics
sortez vos téléphones tous touchent tous
sortez vos téléphones la sortez vos
téléphones et jeté les parterres jeté
par terre si je vois quelqu'un utiliser
son téléphone je fume
ok je fume et filmé un [ __ ] de charger
laborde elle bougeait fois
[ __ ]
[Musique]
et qu'est ce que vous faites là mettez
vous là là je veux tous vous voir vous
[ __ ] voulait pas dû faire ça et faire
mal à la faire
vous devriez partir maintenant je crois
qu'on peut descendre dans la rue en
utilisant cette fenêtre vous devriez
vraiment partir d'ici avant qui vous
tombe dessus de ta gueule vont pas
m'avoir cette fois ci personne ne va me
tomber dessus mais je je parle pas de la
police non techniquement si la police
vous tombe dessus vous le serez en
sécurité on a neigé et tu comprends pas
je veux pas tu entends je veux pas
t'entendre
on sait que c'est une soirée normale
je comprends mais non c'est juste tombé
sur la mauvaise soirée je suis désolé
[ __ ] je te tais tu te tais ce soir on
paie que 70 ans de mama mama c'est une
vieille tueuse à gages qui apprécié au
nez des orphelins pour en faire des
assassins crois tu me faire peur tu
crois que tu vas me faire peur or elle
est l'élue connaît pas la peur
à 8 ans elle vit tout seul dans une
forêt en sibérie dans la neige se
nourrir uniquement de bêtes sauvages
depuis la peur ça existe plus pour elle
c'est qu'elle a peur là non cherchent
uniquement un moyen de vous exterminer
parce que elle aime prendre son temps
turenne malin toi
allez-y vérifier par vous-même mais
dites-moi si elle a l'air d'avoir peur
je commence sérieusement cassé les
[Musique]
on
mais
[Musique]
mais parce que ces gens là ne vous tue
pas vous font disparaître mais
sérieusement la dea des orphelins c'est
quoi cette histoire là d'abord il ya
sergei sagan du lourd ce c'est un brin
un peu moche avec un manteau en fourrure
l'adolescence avec la peau de l'ours il
s'est fait un manteau qui quitte jamais
ses spécialités ses armes blanches
[Musique]
de la merde il a pas une tête de
psychopathe ton mec là une tête de nazes
non ça c'est parce que maman elle fait
en sorte qu'il ressemble à tout le monde
pour mieux infiltrer sa logique bien sûr
par exemple yasuni l angélique et
l'autre une sociopathe qui étrangle ses
victimes nous la deuxième personnalité
éveillé il faut faire attention et la la
comme un petit calcul dans la city
[Musique]
alors sa personnalité c'est là qu'elle
sa deuxième
vous avez vraiment pas de chance au real
et toi bordel
[Musique]
en même temps vous interrompez un moment
super important je sais tout c'est sûr
qu'un échange d'argent n'était prévue ce
soir débute en échange de ses services
il a caché l'argent dans les toilettes
il a besoin du magot pour se construire
une nouvelle saga y avait prévu de
partir avec l'argent dans un étui à
guitare parce que plus tôt dans la
matinée elle a tué son propre frère et
avant d'appeler les secours
il s'était paré du message on raconte
que le corps est encore chaud mais le
problème c'est les jumelles olive
elles sont prêtes à tout pour voler
l'argent les jumelles olive ses deux
soeurs qui ont pour habitude de se
repasser pour la même personne
elle utilise les mêmes habits voit comme
ça ils peuvent poignardé dans le dos et
dans le ventre au même moment joli à
voir
parce qu'elles savent pas les
joliettains seco soutient et sergei
s'aiment d'un amour passionnel est
interdite depuis des années pour
protéger sergei souvenirs s'apprêtait à
être enlevé les jumelles olives mais
celle là vous êtes intervenu et que
l'exemple chadrac à leur compte
en plus je crois qu'il reste de la place
dans les sacs poubelles
[Musique]
non
la dame mme hama je tenais à m'excuser
pour je savais pas pour vos trucs j'ai
rien vu l'enjeu je vais y aller et
surtout vous inquiétez pas un cil aussi
la police arrive nous on va pas vous
balancer on a notre honneur quoi c'est
un peu un peu dans notre sens ouais
ouais parce que je vous ai pas dit mais
s'est aguerri sonia léger mais olive et
moi on vient d'une autre planète
quoi quoi quoi quoi ouais en fait le
buzz s'est écrasé sur terre et mama nous
a reconnus va nous aider à retourner sur
la toile lettre qui est derrière la lune
ce qui fait qu'en fait on est un peu
tous et si les orphelins assassins et
alliés mais c'est quoi ça hilton ma
gueule ou quoi
c'est quoi ces conneries daniel là
qu'est ce qui se passe là [ __ ] il dit
la vérité dans un orgue tut tut tut va
dévoiler notre secret notre identité
comme ça tu sais comment sont les
humains heaven ou capturés et nous
disséqués je suis désolé d'avoir très
trahi notre famille mais tu dois faire
attention à toi et à ton une enveloppe
le corps paraît encore pour elle voit la
zone org
mon frère pardonne moi je
on va réparer le vaisseau est rentré
chez nous d'un la lune sur la planète
xantia monsieur virer mon frère y a rien
fait je peux sans nuit pour construire
le nouveau souffle
[Musique]
c'est un progrès
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah ah ah
c'est une voiture tout quoi santia c'est
une voiture de papa ex que gérard titre
tu
oh ma chérie tu a commenté des
stripteaseurs
je
tommy
puis
[Musique]
bonjour moi c'est pas du tout pour une
dédicace ans et plus pour vous donner un
petit coup de main parce que j'ai relevé
une incohérence dans l'histoire la
cohérence c'est à dire excusez moi
monsieur vous attendez quoi par une
incohérence exactement démettra ne peut
pas voyager dans le temps avec la
religion bien sûr que si d'émettre un
peu faire ça elle n'est pas de la même
temporalité ses principes tels là ok
d'accord déjà du passé qui sont s'y
croirait presse la la cité et démons
biais des mots mais ils ne sont plus sur
la première planète et ça c'est une
question plane attiches la temporalité
c'est le voyage dans la relique avec des
réglettes n'ont plus rien à voir là
dedans
entre à
mon frère
un foehn
kleiza
[Musique]
soudeur
je
à présent
[Musique]
a menti
était temps
[Musique]
non
à
une
[Musique]
encore
mon frère
[Musique]